foreign
feels this way civilization has made
great social advances over the decades
and centuries Progressive changes in
laws legislation and attitudes around
the world have in some areas brought the
diversity of race and gender at social
levels that approximate Martin Luther
King Jr's famous line from his 63 I Have
a Dream speech
I have a dream that my four little
children will one day live in a nation
where they will not be judged by the
color of their skin but by the content
of their character
one thought experiment Bears this truth
imagine you're offered the opportunity
to enter a time machine
and go back to any previous moment in
human history
when and where would you choose
the white cisgender heterosexual male
has his pick of the timeline
this traveler to the Past who will be
welcomed everywhere and everywhere
if that's not you then you better think
hard about the time and place you'd like
to arrive
are you female a person of color
disabled queer or any combination of
these
when was it better for you
a thousand years ago 500 a hundred fifty
years ago ten five
for me I'm good with the present
I'd rather not be declined a taxi ride
overlooked for job opportunities denied
a bank loan or redlined from my choice
of housing
with childhood Ambitions of being a
scientist I don't want to be someone's
servant nor do I fancy being purchased
and owned by another human being who
thinks I'm not entirely human
come to think of it I'd rather visit the
future
as I presume the pressure naturally
Progressive Unitarian Minister Theodore
Parker would too as he wrote in each
fifty three I do not pretend to
understand the moral Universe the ark is
a long one my eye reaches but little
ways I cannot calculate the curve and
complete the figure by the experience of
sight I can Divine it by conscience and
for what I can see I am sure it bends
towards Justice
do we recognize highlight and embrace
diversity or do we aspire to not notice
it at all
imagine if race gender expression and
ethnicity were as irrelevant to our
judgments of people as what brand of
toothpaste they used or whether they
prefer waffles over pancakes
my sentiments align with the visiting
alien on this one consider
extraterrestrials so different from us
in every way
that to them all humans are
indistinguishable from one another no
matter how much we distinguish ourselves
all they see of us are four limbs a
torso and a head
sounds insensitive of them but we're no
better for most animals on Earth we have
no idea at a glance and probably not
even close up what their gender is well
whether there's some subtle difference
between the coloration or plumage on one
member of a species relative to another
we silently think that way about Urban
pigeons and especially suburb and
goldfish
parents surreptitiously swap live ones
for the dead ones that they just killed
this typically happens while their kids
are away at camp as they attempt to
conceal that they've overfed or never
fed gold being bubbles
for most of us
seeing one goldfish seen them all our
visiting alien sees us segregate
stratify and subjugate others Among Us
based on features they hardly notice
bearing witness to our divided ways in
response to All That should be hid
relevant to the content of our character
our space alien would surely phone home
and Report Surefire evidence that
there's no sign of intelligent life on
Earth
[Music]